el hospital de maternidad de gersón bajo
ataque según las autoridades ucranianas
en las últimas 24 horas las fuerzas
rusas han lanzado más de 33 misiles
contra objetivos civiles en la localidad
recientemente liberada mientras el
kremlin lo niega las madres todavía se
reponen del miedo
fue aterrador también inesperado las
explosiones empezaron bruscamente la
manilla de la ventana comenzó a
arrancarse cristales o todavía me
tiemblan las manos francamente
en estas salas de maternidad ahora
vacías descansaban las mujeres
embarazadas y algunas madres que
acababan de dar a luz pocos momentos
antes del ataque que no dejó muertos ni
heridos pero sí daños en las
infraestructuras
después del primer golpe hubo dos uno
fue justo aquí hemos cubierto el cráter
en el segundo pueden ver las
consecuencias tras el ataque empezaron
las explosiones inmediatamente
trasladamos a las mujeres pasadas al
sótano y luego las trasladamos a nuestra
sala principal donde pasaron la noche
en el momento de la explosión según las
autoridades locales había cinco mujeres
con recién nacidos y personalmente
dentro del hospital
[Música]
Desde esa sala salimos a un pasillo
después del primer bombardeo Entonces
fui a la sala de partos había un bebé lo
cogí lo llevé a un pasillo después
reunimos a todas las mujeres y las
llevamos al sótano
las tropas ucranianas recuperaron la
estratégica ciudad sureña hace un mes en
una de las liberaciones que más júbilo
causó a los ucranianos pero en los
últimos días el kremlin ha intensificado
sus ataques con morteros y artillería
presionando las líneas del frente de las
regiones orientales del país el sábado
un bombardeo Ruso acabó con la vida de
diez personas en gersón por lo que
muchos están pensando en abandonar sus
hogares Y desplazarse a otras áreas